back in the day i had an rv
and for whatever reason we had i had
taken the mint chocolate chip ice cream
and put it in the rv freezer for some
reason i forget why
and
you know when that when that stuff's in
the freezer in the house it was like oh
cool i'm gonna get it's right there
we're gonna go get it right but i guess
i wasn't dopamine fueled enough
like three four five days went by before
i was like all right i really want it so
i'm gonna go get it well it's
it is the molecule of drive the way to
think about dopamine is that it is a
non-infinite
yet renewable resource non-infinite yet
renewable what do i mean by that well
this relates to the energy drink
caffeine question should you be doing
all this stuff
just as
adrenaline epinephrine is released in
response to psychological stressors
physical stressors cold water final
exams you know broken relationship
excitement
these are generic molecules right i mean
they're used to create activation states
in the body dopamine is the molecule of
motivation pursuit and desire
and it can be triggered by a number of
different things
however it is a
non-infinite yet renewable resource so
if you
have too big a dopamine
release
let's say from methamphetamine cocaine
damn we're going we're going there we're
going there
okay or or let's say
to be fair because i i you know know
people or from um being in a lot of
gunfights in in a short period of time
the period immediately after that will
involve a mirror symmetric decrease in
dopamine you don't go back down to
baseline you go below baseline
so
we all should guard our dopamine peaks
very carefully a little bit goes a long
way a lot goes even further but it also
takes you down deeper afterwards this is
the basis of addiction
and this is the beautiful work of anna
lemke and rob malenka at stanford and
elsewhere
showing that it when it goes down do we
want it back right now ah so the the dip
afterwards is actually associated with a
molecule called dinorphin which is the
opposite of endorphin
and involves pain in the body so for
every bit of pleasure that we get from
pursuit and getting the thing that we
were pursuing the crash that comes
afterwards feels
painful and
all that we need to do in order to
return to a baseline of dopamine renew
that resource
is to wait and make sure that we don't
try and trigger yet more dopamine in
that time
so you asked about should i be taking
caffeine in addition to training and
blasting music i always say people
differ on this spectrum but be careful
about stacking dopamine training itself
is a stimulus for dopamine release cold
water is a stimulus for dopamine release
but if you start doing training
cold water
listening to your your favorite music
plus you're taking let's say some
stimulant doesn't obviously the stimulus
we've been talking about are terrible
but some of the the stronger stimulants
out there
used to be ephedrine back when i was in
college but now
people taking adult adderall
is that ritual it's now illegal right
right now illegal yeah
i had a guy work with unfortunately he
died but he
you would you would see like he was in
my platoon you would see
he he he would take that he called it
rippy rip
actually you can tell if somebody has a
lot of dopamine and adrenaline in their
system just by looking at them their
pupils are big so somewhat paradoxically
when pupils are big your visual aperture
is narrow that just has to do with the
with the so-called accommodation of the
eye the optics of the eye so remember
big pupils means somebody is high on
their own dopamine and adrenaline could
be drug-induced could be situational et
cetera small pupils are going to be a
relaxed state now of course it's also
going to be modulated by how bright it
is an environment because of the way
these systems work
but when you can see somebody wide-eyed
well dopamine and adrenaline also do
something else they actually trigger
activation of the brainstem cranial
nuclei that cause opening of the eyelids
they also cause an eyes up effect when
we get sleepy what happens our eyes go
down when we're awake eyelids are open
and eyes are up they might not be up
like this these would relate to three
different cranial nerve nuclei for the
future med students you'll learn what
these are
so
it all makes perfect sense when when
because nature is beautiful and the
biology is laid out for us but if we
start stacking behaviors plus
pharmacology plus you know mindsets that
increase dopamine great but what that
means is that if you get a really big
dopamine increase well then that
afternoon you might not feel the drive
to do the work you might think why am i
sleeping in the after why am i kind of
less motivated or next day for training
without that pharmacology
you're thinking oh yeah that the workout
isn't i don't get quite as intense a
contraction with my muscles
exactly
like that
well i'm just thinking about it because
you know a lot of times people ask me
you know i have a hard time you know
like i get fired up to do stuff but then
i don't actually do it you know that's a
common sort of thing for humans
and and now i can kind of track it a
little bit oh you got yourself super
worked up
[Music]
and then you let that go or you you know
maybe you work for a little bit of time
you know like right hey writing a book
right i've written a bunch of books
you're not like hyped to write the book
you might you're like oh man it's going
to be i'm and you that only lasts for
seven minutes of typing bro that's it
it's chop wood carry yeah yeah then it's
like oh this is just gonna suck and
that's just the way it is but now i
realize if you this is what i like about
this if you're aware
of the fact
that oh this is my dopamine crash and i
can't ex i shouldn't anticipate
continued hype through this situation i
need to push through it that's that's
good awareness to have definitely and
you know nowadays you hear especially in
silicon valley about dopamine fasting
you know people i don't even want to
look at somebody else's face i'm not
going to eat any you know tasty food i'm
not going to do anything that stimulates
dopamine sure that will reset what you
find pleasurable but let's be realistic
the better way to do things would be to
modulate dopamine release control it
make it work for you and everyone's
going to differ so for some people it's
got to be music the pre-workout the you
know
four cups of espresso and and you know
and someone's screaming in their face
that they have to do it well for other
people
require require fewer of those variables
but everyone needs to learn how they
feel both before during and after a
behavior you know i think the right
amount of exercise is what you can do
consistently and train hard but that
also allow you to perform unless you're
an athlete and that's your your
profession to be able to do the other
things throughout the day that are
beneficial to you and of course some
people are training late in the day and
i have no problem with that
i got kind of attacked by the the um
the uh fitness anistas recently or
whatever you call them online because i
said you know training early in the days
that's this dopamine pulse like training
late in the day has been shown in these
19 studies sure i'm sure for when your
body temperature is elevated later in
the day
um you know lubrication of the joints
and you know mental acuity sure but for
most people who just need to get more
movement are trying to maximize focus on
productivity throughout the day early
day training is going to be probably the
better option but bet sometimes is
better than no time but if you're
training late in the day
and you're getting a big increase in
body temperature and you're doing it
under bright lights and you're drinking
a pre-workout and you're wondering why
you can't sleep at night it's you know
you don't have to be sigmund freud or a
neuroscientist to understand that you're
basically just have your body you're
cranking your body temperature up hence
a lot of these technologies and here
this isn't a promotion we don't at least
not now don't have any relationship to
anything i won't even name them there
are a lot of technologies now about
making your bed cool
this mat or that this you know to cool
down your butt your body temperature at
night so you can sleep so if you start
thinking about this in kind of a
rational structure it makes sense it
also makes sense why
for instance after a big win sometimes
we feel a crash
and we need some time to reset and that
lower depression sometimes people make
the mistake of going out and pursuing
more dopamine one of the areas that i
have real concern about just because i
hear about it so often and it wasn't an
issue when i was growing up is a lot of
young guys in particular approach me
because they're
based on the questions i'm getting
they're watching a lot of really intense
pornography
and that has we know their studies now
going on at stanford and elsewhere
pornography it creates a strong dopamine
rush these are very primitive pathways
that
in some ways can overwhelm the dopamine
system and then you know another thing
is happening so a lot of young guys are
getting all this arousal from watching
other people have sex and then they're
in the real world scenario and it's like
wait you're no longer third person in
this you're in you're actually in this
scene and and it's completely collapsing
them and so i'm not one of these
anti-porn people i you know i'm not here
to judge i'm just a scientist i'm
reporting the i always say i'm not a
doctor i don't prescribe things i'm a
professor so i profess things you can
decide what you want to do with it or
not but if you once you understand
dopamine that all makes perfect sense
they're getting this enormous dopamine
release from something that is external
to them and real life you know may not
mimic the intensity of the combination
of variables right
or people are exercising for a little
while and it's all exciting to them and
they're and they're you're taking tons
and tons of pharmacology to do it and
then they kind of lose motivation well
it remember non-infinite yet renewable
resource